beaba phys ed mountain would offer of a
German automobile club Castro tesla's
New Model S performance a sedan said to
have a range of up to 500 kilometers on
electric power alone the Tesla Model S
performance accelerates magnificently
the electric motor mounted over the rear
axle puts out 310 kilowatts of power
with a maximum torque of some 600 Newton
meters right from the start
it makes the sprint from 0 to 100 just
4.4 seconds and it's even more
impressive when overtaking moving up
from 60 to 100 and a bear 2.1 seconds
the top speed is 210 km/h the Tesla
Model S has a body that just won't quit
blending the most beautiful curves of
italian and british design even if it is
built in the united states its slender
silhouette recalls the elegance of a
Maserati or Jaguar but minus the
tailpipes rude / says the sedan drives
as quietly as a whisper unless the
driver switches on the sound studio
package the Erik suspension does more
for the driving comfort than do the
outside tires the steering response
nicely and in general the model s as an
outstanding premiere for Tesla's
proprietary development the Tesla Model
S's batteries are integrated into its
floor lowering the center of gravity but
sudden swerves won't throw it off
balance Annie da sees brake test it came
to a stop in a very good 34 meters but
modern assist systems like the emergency
brake assist are not available for the
new Tesla the Tesla's classy interior is
dominated by a 17 inch touch screen that
displays every imaginable bit of
information it also saves the settings
for everything from the headlights to
the sunroof but having to work even the
simplest functions over menus can
distract from the task of driving the
cargo space folds out from 435 to 845
litres in volume the Tesla s is entirely
emissions-free the dynamometer yielded a
maximum range of 400 15 kilometers using
an 85 kilowatt battery that works out to
a consumption rate of 23 and a half
kilowatt hours per hundred kilometers or
a carbon footprint of 136 g/km mantener
door fur concludes the new Tesla Model S
proved to be a street worthy car with a
relatively long range but it takes over
50 hours to
charge the batteries fully from a
household outlet so a three-phase power
supply helps at a list price of over one
hundred nine thousand euros for this top
line model we shouldn't even have to
think about that Oh can problem is I'm